he makes his debut this week from Royal
Birkdale at the Open Championship he'll
be on the course reporting during the
network's nearly 50 hours of live
coverage and bones joins us now how
nervous are you bones I'm feeling okay
today but I'll definitely be a little
nervous tomorrow when we get going
all right how weird is it to be walking
a golf course without carrying a bag
it's extremely weird and I caught a lot
of grief from Maya like my caddy friends
not wearing long pants which is
something I haven't done in a long time
either what is your goal what is the job
what are you going to give us that we
couldn't get from another on course
reporter hopefully breaking down the the
player caddy dynamic a little bit talk a
little bit more about you know the whole
risk reward thing and conservative play
versus aggressive clay and you know iron
play is going to be so big this week
here Birkdale because it's a second shot
golf course so hopefully just talking a
lot about the guys taking on risk and
whether or not it will it won't pay off
why is there a chance you were going to
caddy in the Open Championship no no
there wasn't I mean when when Phil and I
split Tommy and Roy from NBC got in
touch pretty quickly and I didn't have
anything going on post split with Phil
and he got in touch and that's why I'm
here we look really proud to be here you
told me a while ago that you knew that
there could come a day when you and Phil
split up I think three or four years ago
we had the conversation and I think
we're talking about Stevie Williams and
Tiger and I said are you prepared for a
day like that and you said you were but
in reality were you ready for that
breakup when Phil said let's split up
well you know it was it was a decision
that was we both came to I wouldn't say
either one of us said more than the
other hey you know let's not do this I
mean you know we were talking about
about where we were and what was going
on and you know came to the conclusion
that it would be best if we did so yeah
I would I will you know I understand
it's part of the business I mean I've
been out here long enough you hear these
crazy stories about Claire caddy
ring two firings and you know anything's
possible so I was just really grateful
for a to time we had and for the you
know getting to watch all his wins and
the great things that went on while we
were together how close did you ever
come to getting fired before or
splitting up with Phil well he could
probably answer that question better
than me I mean you know listen every
every player Italian relationship is
going to have its peaks and valleys and
ending up in my opinion a very good
caddy if you don't you know disagree
with your player when you really think
you should so Phil was great Phil's not
a blamer that's that was the reason I
was with him as long as I was and and
and you know he takes a lot of
responsibility for what goes on out
there but there was never a time you
know prior to us splitting who I thought
oh my gosh I may not have this guy next
week how many times during the course of
a year could you overrule Phil did you
did you have like trump cards that you
could play and say I did you have veto
power over Phil and how often can you
use it I got one veto a year so you know
we would certainly have gladly taken a
couple more but I got one a year I was
glad to have it a couple times try to
use it I try to use it at a 2002 open
over here and he informed me they were
domestic only so as I think you get out
of the country so we had we had a pretty
good argument about that how many miles
do you think you've won somebody told me
recently that definitely have gone
enough to have gone around the globe we
like one and a half times with Phil
something like that and a buddy of mine
that wore one of those step leaders says
as we go roughly 19 or 20 thousand steps
a day 19 to 20 thousand steps a day
never get tired like dizzy sick well I'm
I got really sick in Mexico this year
but that had something to do with a foot
something I ain't but also be dazed okay
yeah but no I mean I'm still you know a
a great player and you're in the game
out there you talk about what's going on
and maybe the rush of adrenaline you
have you know teeing off on Thursday at
these tournaments is like nothing else
who's your pick to win Jordan Spieth's
and I picked a win for the reason that
it's not a driver golf course you know I
think a guy like Dustin Johnson said
he's only going to hit three or four a
day so you position yourself off the tee
and then you attack from there and you
know being from Texas Jordans a great
player in the wind and I also think when
you have to have a great week through
2530 feet he's about as good a putter as
there is so he would be my pick how you
going to feel with Phil wins I feel very
happy for him I'll tell you what this is
a phenomenal course Phil I mean you just
you know is I think he said he's not
he's not hitting a driver this week he's
just going to put it in play off the tee
and he's the most underrated iron player
in the game so it wouldn't shock me at
all if he had a phenomenal week here
have you ever muttered under your breath
and Phil most yes yeah I think every
every caddy that's ever picked up a bag
on if it's here or the local Country
Club has done that but give me an idea
like if if you he begrudging like you
wanting to hit something he doesn't want
to hit it he uses his club and then he
doesn't hit it well and then do you
mutter something under your breath at
him yeah no I mean you know Phil and I
had a great relationship I think it's
Thursday that's why it lasted 25 years I
mean you know 95 times out of a hundred
we were thinking the same thing and on
those occasions when we warn't you know
we talked it out and he'd make his
decision but I there was not much for me
to mutter about because again he's that
golfer that takes a lot of
responsibility he's not a blamer like
some guys can be and he was you know
he'd say something like oh man I took
the club out of the bag that's on me and
when you're working in that kind of
environment as a caddy you're extremely
lucky and the relationships are we going
to last a long time
explain to me how a caddy gets paid I
know it's different but is it a lump was
it a lump sum and then a percentage on
victories for you is that how it worked
uh it I've only ever heard of one caddy
in my 25 years of doing it that was paid
a yearly salary so everyone's basically
caddies paid for their own expenses so
they're going to get you know some money
you know each week with a caddy to
hopefully you know pay for their travel
and then you know you're going to get a
percentage of the players earnings and
that will and the percentages you know
will depend you'll get more for wind and
then you will for finishing for dia if I
if I said you can have your career as a
caddy with Phil or you could be the
100th ranked golfer in the world so
you'd actually be playing or you could
have you could be a caddy for 25 years
for Phil Mickelson yeah that would be a
no-brainer for me I take the 25 years
with Phil because I went to the last 22
team events be it Ryder Cups or
presidents cups I saw some things that
the Masters in the Open Championship
that you know I'll be thinking about a
lot when I'm a very old man and those
experiences I you know wouldn't have it
the hundred best play on the tour what
memorabilia did you keep from your
relationship partnership with Phil get
God's got some flags you know for the
flag sticks that's the caddy tradition
just when the player wins obviously they
get the trophy and the caddy gets the
flag off the plastic off off 18 green
which is really cool and you know you've
won quite a few times so that's a nice
thing you know a lot of memories you
know the great thing about what can
forget like Phil is the people that you
meet you know and and some of the
relationships you form you know guys I
would you know never expect to hang out
with it that's that's been a great part
of it also you get to wear the green
jacket at all I have never put on the
green jacket to be honest with you um
yeah that the first year he won the
first time he won in 2004 I went over to
his house that night about 11 o'clock at
night yet sweats on and a jacket and he
wasn't taking that setting off anytime
soon
but I don't blame these guys that you
know if I won that term and I'd be
wearing it everywhere so good for them
well have fun this week I know it will
feel a little stir
change and the fact that you're going to
be talking about people that you used to
be in that position but the more insight
you can give us the feel of putting us
out there I think the better it's going
to be the viewers experience so do your
best have fun and you know good luck and
I really appreciate it thanks for having
me on all right that's bollocks makai
phil Mickelson's former county the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience